près de qui est notre correspondant en
Ukraine Gulliver crack bonjour Gulliver
Gulliver vous êtes dans une localité un
tout près de Kiev quel est la situation
sur place là où vous vous trouvez alors
on se parle
en fait on n'est pas vraiment tout près
de Kiev on est en temps normal à 2h30 de
route de Kiev un voyage qui nous a pris
10 heures hier à cause de l'exode de la
capitale
ukrainienne ici on est vraiment dans le
centre de l'Ukraine loin de toute grande
ville et bien sûr beaucoup plus en
sécurité qui Kiev mais tout de même on
sent que la guerre est présente ici
aussi il y a une base militaire à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de là où je me
trouve en ce moment qui a été frappé
jeudi pendant la matinée de soldats sont
morts ce qui fait craindre plus de
frappe à la population locale ici et
surtout ce qu'on a ressenti ici c'est
les normes mobilisation que ce soit les
hommes qui partent
s'inscrire à la défense territoriale ou
à l'armée on a assisté à vénitia la
capitale régionale
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
des jeunes hommes qui arrivaient pour
partir justement à Kiev pour la défense
de la capitale ce qui ne vont pas se
battre les armes à la main se mobilisent
pour fournir des aliments des denrées
alimentaires à l'armée ou encore
d'autres choses d'autres choses de
défense dont ils ont besoin les blindés
pardon les blindages c'est ça le mot que
je cherchais les volontaires surtout des
femmes évidemment qui font ça et
vraiment le sentiment que le pays
entière se mobilise et beaucoup de gens
nous ont dit on a bien compris que il
n'y a plus que nous pour nous défendre
même si une femme m'a dit qu'elle est
quand même très reconnaissante de
l'assistance qui arrive à l'ukrainement
de l'Occident mais a-t-elle dit il
fallait commencer avec ça en 2014 déjà
et comprendre la menace que poser
Vladimir Poutine et la Russie Gulliver
un mot également avec vous des combats à
l'échelle nationale la résistance
ukrainienne n'apparaît plus plus féroce
que prévu l'évolution des combats
alors aujourd'hui il y a eu des tirs
d'artillerie sur arkives
ça a été domicile multiple de type grade
qui ont touché des bâtiments
résidentiels et c'est le cas aussi de
certaines qui est une banlieue de Mario
Paul cette fameuse ville portuaire dans
le dans le basse tout près de là où se
situait la ligne de France pendant les 8
dernières années dans le don de basque
ça c'est dans l'est du pays dans le sud
du pays j'ai vu une vidéo de comment
juste après l'incident
une ambulance qui transportait des
blessés a été frappé et le chauffeur de
l'ambulance et mort il y a ils attaquent
sur tous les fronts il y a même eu et là
aussi j'ai vu la vidéo une colonne de
tank qui venait dans la région de
tchernikif c'est juste au nord de Kiev
et on a vu les habitants d'une ville
dans cette région qui essayait comme il
pouvait arrêter ces temps qu'il y a eu
même un homme qui s'est mis devant un
ton Crush pour le défier à l'avancée à
rouler sur lui mais ses camarades l'ont
sortie de la situation craignant que le
soldat russe allait juste faire
exactement cela et rouler sur cette
habitant la
résidence de ce village qui a filmé la
vidéo on entend savoir son commentaire
en disant que cette colonne de temps qui
est infinie ça n'en finit pas son nom
finit pas à devenir bien sûr ce sont des
tanks qui roulent vers la capitale qui
est merci beaucoup Gulliver crack pour
toutes ces précisions donc en direct
depuis le centre de l'Ukraine donc on